well I sort of stumbled into the role of
being the voice of the emo indie rock
movement but that was just to pay the
bills really I wanted to break into
late-night television production I guess
you could say I'm a happy gilmore of emo
hi my name is Conor Oberst and I'm a
production assistant at cone what I love
about TV production is no one gives me
special treatment here just because I
was a famous musician you have to earn
it
hey Amy how's it going it's just so cool
to see how a TV show works the
transitions been a little rocky my brain
is just so good at coming up with sad
songs about how we're just pawns in this
[ __ ] up game that sometimes the lyrics
just slip out cold most and just a
sleeve to the man no one speaks for you
no one understands but everyone at Conan
is super understanding and really trying
to help me coffee you won't save you but
it helps just work until you hate
yourself every day is a fresh new hell
9:00 to 5:00 back to the start a new
wards time the chip board George Bush
them boys to die no war Iraq's not a
place it's just the word useless time
George Bush is not even the [ __ ]
president anymore Connor I'm sorry I
don't like it when my brain does that
any more than right you do okay so
there's this other PA she started right
around the same time I did my name is
Femi she is really great coffee time is
my favorite time coffee time is my
favorite oh we all really really love
her sometimes I even get an interactive
language she's so cool and he's such a
great guy the 50 jokes prefer a to watch
the bottom line keep staring out the
glowing screen and watch it all go by
before they can't exploit you
advertising laughs the Tommen tells us
jokes wants residents before he croaks
his red hair shakes it's already
hey hey Conan it it's it's Connor from
bright eyes lap I played you shake yeah
you're great I remember you
yeah we're just colleagues yeah talks to
me you don't talk to me you don't play
you're a [ __ ] PA okay we need some new
jokes everyone here is really
constructive no I don't miss my old
music career with all the adoring fans
and glowing reviews don't you go back to
Third Eye Blind
I loved being a PA yeah I'll probably do
this for a while but it's kind of a
[ __ ] job I hope I never have to
leave coming you're a [ __ ] PA it's
really really fun
fun is the opiate of the masses
looking through these rose-colored
glasses no no I'm sorry